was that the longest Smackdown I've ever
recorded quite possibly thank you to
brilliant for sponsoring a section of
this video get smarter at maths and
physics free solving problems at
brilliant org slash Simon Clark the
comments section on YouTube is a
dangerous place at the best of times but
when you make videos about a
controversial for some reason topic like
climate change then it tends to get more
intense in this video series I have been
looking through the comments on my
videos about climate change and reacting
and responding it to some of the points
that have been raised so let's do some
more of that what a load of crap tell me
what percentage of warming as if warming
isn't like a term like a scientific term
warming tell me what percentage of
warming is humanity responsible for by
some people's estimates actually more
than a hundred percent which let me
explain so climate scientists will look
at two kinds of forcings on the global
climate they'll look at the human
forcing co2 emissions for example and
also the natural forcing so that can be
background changes in the you know the
US coming out of the last ice age it
could be changes in solar forcing any
number of factors which you know do
contribute to the global average
temperature in order to accurately model
the observed changes in the Earth's
climate over the past century we have to
account for human interference there is
absolutely no doubt that humans have
influenced the climate and the amount of
warming that has taken place due to
humans is approximately a hundred
percent the extra uncertainty on top of
that is the natural forcings
so it's possible that the earth would
have warmed slightly in the absence of
humans but also it's possible that the
earth might have cooled in the absence
of humans in which case humans are
actually responsible for more than a
hundred percent of the observed warming
because cooling would have happened if
there were no humans which is not
something that we are totally sure about
we are sure that humans have ruled of
the climate we're not sure quite how
whether it's a hundred 102 or ninety
eight percent it's in Elon Musk hands
now our space Jesus ok
what mentally unstable people it's the
weather I'm sure this is something that
a lot of people do understand but this
is something I see frequently enough
that I should probably explicitly
address it there is a definite
difference between climate and weather
weather is the short-term variations in
atmospheric parameters so rain Sun
cloudy whereas climate is the long-term
average of those quantities and the
change in climate is the long-term
change in weather effectively the
problem is that humans are very bad at
detecting small long-term changes
especially when we have large short-term
variations so that variant certainly in
the UK from day-to-day in temperatures
and the amount of Sun that we have is
far far larger than any annual increase
that we would see due to anthropogenic
forcing on the climate it's very easy to
a conflate climate and weather because
they are related but definitely distinct
topics but also as humans just difficult
to actually believe that there is a slow
small background change that when added
up over the course of a couple of
decades or a century is going to be very
significant by the way if you are
enjoying this video please do give it a
like as I said in the last video these
videos that I make about climate tend to
be targeted by YouTube bots in some
cases and posted on conspiracy websites
so they tend to get flooded with
downvotes
so if you have learned something if you
are enjoying it then do pop it alike and
it helps the channel undo some of the
damage that the algorithm can inflict on
it anyway back to the comments so the
climate models are proof of human-caused
are those the same models that failed to
predict the climate of the last 20 years
this is a very common argument that will
fine being used by climate sceptics that
the models used by atmospheric
scientists have no relation to reality
and they're unable to predict what's
happening this is an interesting
argument because it's completely wrong
the global circulation and climate
models that atmospheric scientists use
have been shown to accurately predict
the changes in the Earth's atmosphere
and also actually in the Earth's ocean
and there's two ways that we can be
pretty confident about that firstly is
forecasting which is where you make a
prediction of what's going to happen in
the future and
you have to wait for however long it is
that you forecast into the future to see
how you've bitten and the models have
done a very good job of that but you can
also do hind casting which is to start
at the present and instead of iterating
forwards in the future you iterate
backwards which is super simple to do in
a climate model you literally just
change the time step from positive to
negative and then you go backwards in
time and so starting from your initial
conditions and given data about for
example co2 concentrations changing over
time you can see if your model
accurately predicts further back into
the past and global climate models have
done a very good job of predicting right
back to 1900 so this idea that client
levels don't match reality is simply not
true it's one of these lies that just
gets tasted often enough that people
just kind of start to believe it because
they never check to come back to
something else in this comment though
that the climate models are proof of
human-caused in a sense yes because
climate models are able to disentangle
what's called natural forcings so that
could be changes in these Suns in tennis
tea or volcanic eruptions or what have
you but also then the human forcings so
things like carbon dioxide emissions and
it's been very clearly shown that you
need to account for the human forcings
in order to make your model match
reality if you put only natural forcings
into your model then it doesn't produce
the observed warming the fact of the
matter is that climate scientists using
an anthropogenic principle that that
humans are forcing the climate aren't
able or have been able to predict what's
going to happen in the atmosphere
climate skeptics without accounting for
human influence have not an actually one
further thing there's a frequent
criticism leveled at these models that
our climate scientists always overhype
and overestimate how much warming will
happen and there's obviously uncertainty
in any form of prediction this is
actually why climate scientists do so
many forms of predictions so we get an
ensemble forecasts of lots of different
climate models with ever so slightly
different tuned models but in actual
fact a lot of the time we have been
under estimating so if you look at
Arctic sea ice extent it has been
collapsing at a rate faster than climate
scientists have on the whole predicted
ditto for sea level rise the sea level
has been rising at rather the sea level
rises
accelerating at a greater rate than
scientists would say it's still within
the error bars but at the upper end so
that indicates that our predictions are
actually under estimating the
anthropogenic impact on climate is that
the longest Smackdown I've ever recorded
quite possibly Simon I highly suspect
the deep inside your flawed brain you
realize just how full of you are we the
discerning minds of this planet now know
without equivocation that all of the
planets and the tearin system have had
the feith an out of them this is due to
the sun's solar minimum opening the door
to galactic radiation as well as waves
of energy from belching black holes the
region of space we are now in contains
areas of highly charged energy and in
some cases and in some instances
radiates temperatures of over 10,000
degrees F my friends when you pass a
rocky snowball through an oven the top
and bottom melt first I can't believe I
read a comment the other day that said
it education was over funded someone
clearly hasn't heard of co2 saturation
so this is actually a more
scientifically interesting idea to bring
up this concept of co2 saturation this
is the idea that co2 in the atmosphere
already absorbs basically all of the
thermal energy that is emitted by the
surface so if you're adding more co2 to
the atmosphere you're not going to cause
it to absorb more of that radiation it's
already as maximum or it's saturated and
this is almost correct but it's missing
quite an important fundamental of
atmospheric science so to break this
down firstly does co2 already absorb all
of the infrared radiation basically that
is emitted by the Earth's surface
yes that's true so by adding more co2
you're not going to be increasing the
amount of infrared radiation that's
absorbed at the Earth's surface by co2
sure that's also correct therefore by
adding more co2 to the atmosphere you
can't cause more global warming no the
way that co2 absorbs infrared radiation
in the atmosphere is a bit like this so
the Earth's surface radiates infrared
radiation and that then is absorbed by
co2 that's close to the surface and I
should point out this has always
happened
always been a greenhouse effect present
in the Earth's atmosphere it's just that
humans have somewhat intensified it the
layer of the atmosphere above the
Earth's surface then re-emits that
radiation as infrared radiation but then
there's another layer of atmosphere
above that whereas it's getting thinner
there is less co2 present and so maybe a
little bit of the infrared will escape
but it's still largely reabsorbed and
then re emitted and this process happens
over and over and over again until you
reach a section in the atmosphere where
the atmosphere above you is so thin that
there's not enough co2 to absorb the
infrared radiation and so it escapes to
space the crucial thing is that the
amount of energy the earth gives out is
it then dependent on how hot that layer
of the atmosphere is and as humans have
been adding more co2 to the atmosphere
it basically raised that emitting all
that radiating height and crucially this
is all happening in the lowest part of
the atmosphere for the troposphere which
is the part of the atmosphere where
temperatures decrease as you get higher
so as you add more co2 to the atmosphere
that means that the temperature of the
emitting layer as it gets higher and
higher in the atmosphere because we've
added more co2 the temperature of that
layer decreases which means the Earth's
been emitting less energy into space
which causes the energy imbalance that
results in global warming and climate
change so while it is correct to say
that the co2 absorption at the surface
is saturated is not correct to say that
it is for the whole atmosphere which
produces more co2 volcanoes or human
activity wait a minute this isn't a
youtube comment at all this is from
brilliant brilliant have been a longtime
supporter of this channel and they have
very kindly agreed to sponsor this video
which I'm very pleased about because
brilliant is all about scientific
literacy and learning through solving
problems they have a huge variety of
courses on their site ranging from the
maths to science the computer science
and they're expanding it all the time
this question actually came from the
wiki that's built into Britain on
climate change which includes questions
that you can interact with talking about
the science of climate change but also
talking about some of the people that
dispute the science and the idea of
scientific literacy in this area where
everybody's had
to do everything from home including
learning then brilliant if you are
interested in science if you're
interested in maths is the perfect
resource I honestly wish that it was
around when I was at university when I
was at school because this would have
helped me in my education so much you
can use brilliant completely for free
but if you would like to upgrade to a
premium membership and get access to the
expertly written courses then go to
brilliant org slash Simon Clark and the
first 200 people to do so will get 20%
off their premium annual subscription
that's it for this video thank you very
much for watching as already said if you
enjoyed it if you learn something to pop
it I like if you'd like to see more of
this kind of content then do subscribe
to the channel and let me know in the
comments what kind of things you'd like
me to talk about in future videos thank
you again for watching I'll see you in
the next one
[Music]